every once in a while you gotta shut  down whether it be a drink or five  uh  call of duty whatever [ __ ] you do yeah  exactly you play video games  uh now i'm not a video game guy and i'm  glad i'm not yeah because i got hooked  on candy crush  for a while and  my girlfriend my ex-girlfriend at the  time was like you gotta stop like you  just sit there and i'll i'll be like oh  [ __ ] it's 5 a.m  and then you lose all the day because  you sleep all day so like is that fun  it's just fun and addictive and your  brain  it gets right in your head and i just  had to delete it off my phone i'm not  one of those guys who was like i had to  delete twitter i can shut that [ __ ] up  but candy crush i just kept going that  you're on the train you're on a plane  it's funny that you're like i have a  problem with candy crush i've literally  watched how much you drank and you've  you've never told me even the whole  problem yeah and you're like [ __ ]  candy crush man you got me man me